hey 42 here the world's oldest living
thing is a patch of mediterranean sea
grass between Spain and Cyprus it is
estimated to be 200 thousand years old
welcome to RIF Paul McCartney is the
only musician who has topped the charts
as a solo artist in a duo in a trio in a
quartet and in a quintet Americans eat
500 million pounds of peanut butter a
year enough to coat the floor of the
Grand Canyon Manchester United is the
most hated brand in Britain and the
seventh most hated in the world when we
blush our stomach lining goes red as
well 90% of the bullet bought by the
Ministry of Defense are used for
training purposes a lethal dose of
caffeine is about 50 double espressos a
father hired over gamers to kill his son
in video games so that he would stop
playing video games and get alive
crocodiles can climb trees
some pigs suffer from misophobia the
fear of mud a study in Texas invited
people to taste wine labeled France
California and Texas nearly all the
tasters rout French as the best but in
fact all three wines were the exact same
Texan wine President Obama's Secret
Service nickname is renegade Ronald
Reagan's nickname was rawhide Bill
Clinton's was eagle and George W Bush
was known as trailblazer Red Bull was
originally called red water buffalo
every time he made a cup of coffee
Beethoven
counted out exactly 60 beams to make
sure it was always exactly the same
strength areas of the moon include the
ocean of storms the marsh of decay and
the lake of death by law
buskers in Dublin must have a repertoire
of at least 20 songs
India has almost 150 5000 post offices
more than any country in the world and
almost twice as many as China thanks for
the view subscribe for more thoughty2
you